I'll go tomorrow I
really beat Harris, I beat
Kobayashi Hey, no, no, no, I
'm still a child
Or leave them in a government facility from the beginning.Because I'm a
princess,
I'm an adult.I've joined the navy, so I'm going to become a decent human being.
I'll show you how to raise them into fine human beings I'll live with these children The accident with Rami
You gave me life
Subaru
I'll be fine
What does Subaru want to say
?  After
all
, I didn't give birth because I wanted you to do
something, I gave birth because I wanted to do something for you.
[Music]
I'm not a queen I'm
laughing at the end
So it's all okay
[music]
finger cut down mac tweet noa first
season of love
There's no such thing as unhappiness,
I'll do it - I'm a middle-aged mother, so please be
perfectly happy all the time.
I want to be a strong mother like my mother someday
.
When
he was about 5 years old,
when he was waiting for the kindergarten bus,
he jumped on the roadway again.  -And only then, my mother-chan
I've been making a lot of money every day, and I'm paying attention to it, and I'm
looking happy.
follow me